so we're finally ready to tie up these
ideas about mapping properties to
counting properties and let's begin with
the remark that we already made that if
there's a bisection from one set to
another if there's a bijection from a
finite set aid we'll finite set B then a
and B have the same size by the way
those vertical bars absolute value of a
when it's a set refers us to the size of
the set for finite sets of it it means
if a has n elements then the absolute
value of a is n ok let's use this
bhaijan idea immediately here's a nice
example suppose you want to figure out
how many subsets are there of a finite
set a and suppose you didn't know yet
all right so what we're asking about is
what's the size of the power set of a
room and the power set of a is all of
the possible subsets of the set a well
suppose a has three elements what is the
power set of a look like if Capital a
has elements little ABC it's a set of
size three then the power set of a is
going to have one subset with no
elements three subsets with one element
they're listed there it's going to have
three more subsets with two elements and
one subset with three elements for a
total of a subset in the power set of a
so let's see what the counting argument
in general would be so suppose that a
has n elements and we'll number them
from a zero up through a n minus 1
because computer scientists usually 0
origin index so a is a set of n elements
indicated there suppose I have some
arbitrary subset of a let's suppose that
it has a zero then there's no a 1 that's
what the space is for it has a 2 it has
a 3 it doesn't have a 4 then it goes on
for a while in some uncertain way and it
ends it actually has the last element a
n minus 1 in it well I can take the
subset like this and cut and have it
correspond to a bit string where I put a
1 where the element is there in the
subset and a 0
where the element is not there in the
subset so there's a 1 because a 1 a 0 is
in the subset followed by a 0 because a
1 is not in the subset followed by two
ones because a 2 and a 3 are in the
subset followed by a 0 because a for is
not and so on ending with a 1 because a
n minus 1 is in the subset so in short
the bit string the cave bit in the
string is 1 if and only if a sub K is in
the set now this clearly defines a
bijection between subsets and strings
because given a subset I can uniquely
determine the string and given the
string I can uniquely determine the
subset so there's one arrow in and one
arrow out of each of those things so I
can immediately conclude then by the by
this by action theorem that the number
of n bit strings is equal to the size of
the power set of a well now every
computer scientist knows how many n bit
strings there are right there are 2 to
the N and bit bit strings and therefore
the power set of a has 2 to the N
elements we can get rid of the end
because it was the size of a and we have
this nice formula the power set the size
of the power set of a finite set a is 2
to the size of a well there are some
more counting rules like the bijection
rule that relates sizes obsessed by
inequalities according to whether the
mappings are surjective injective
functions and so on so let's take a
quick look at those suppose that I have
a surjective function from A to B well
that means there's less than or equal to
one arrow out of every element of a
that's what function means and there is
greater than or equal to one arrow in to
every element of B that's what
surjective means so here's this function
from A to B that means less than or
equal to one arrow out and that means
that there have to be more elements in a
than there are arrows since there's at
most one
arrow out of every element of a and that
accounts for all the arrows so the size
of a has to be Gregor drink'll to the
number of arrows when you have a a
partial function when it's a surjection
that means that there's an arrow coming
in to every element of B that means that
there have to be at least as many arrows
as there are and B because everything in
B has at least one arrow coming in so if
you look at these two pieces the size of
a has to be greater equal to the number
of arrows and the size of B has to be
less than or equal to the number of
arrows putting them together we have the
mapping rule for surjections if I have a
surjective function from A to B it means
the size of a is greater than or equal
to the size of B for finite a and B well
the same argument goes for injections
with an injection I have less than or
equal to one arrow in and what does that
tell me well if it's total then there's
at least one arrow out of everything and
that means that the size of a has to be
less than or equal for the number of
arrows because every element that
contributes an arrow may be more than
one okay if it's an injection there's
less than or equal to one arrow coming
into each element of B that means that B
had better be big enough to catch all
the arrows so the number of arrows has
to be less than or equal to the size of
B put those two inequalities together
and you find that if you have a total
injective relation from A to B that
implies that the size of a is less than
or equal to the size of B for finite a
and B the statement here that it's a
total injective relation is for
generality but the truth is whenever
there's a total injective relation
there's also a total injective function
I'll leave that to a class exercise to
work out so to summarize what we can do
is characterize these kinds of of jetson
relations between sets so let's define a
by B so this is going to be a binary
relation between
two sets a and B and its meaning is that
there's a bi action from A to B so the
definition of BI is a binary relation
where the domain and the codomain are
the class of finite sets or all sets for
that matter
Serg be a surge be is means that there
is a surjective function from A to B
again surge is a binary relation between
sets and finally a inge B says there's a
total injection relation from A to B so
we have those three relations between
sets and what we've just shown is that
if there's a bisection between a and B
that's true implies that the size of a
is equal to the size of B and in fact
it's not hard to prove the converse if
the size of a and the size of B are the
same then it's easy enough to find a
bisection between them
similarly if there's a surjection from A
to B that's true if and only if the size
of a is greater than equal to the size
of B and if there's an injection from A
to B that's true if and only if the size
of a is less than or equal to the size
of B so the this the existence of these
kinds of of relations between sets is a
handle on their relative sizes and this
implies for finite sets a and B because
we don't really know what the size of
infinite sets are so it wouldn't make
sense to talk about the mapping lemma
for infinite sets however we can ask
some questions about infinite sets so
one a natural question to ask is let's
look at some finite properties if the
size of a and B are the same and the
size of B and C are the same obviously
the size of a and C are the same and
that corresponds directly to an
assertion about bi because the size of a
equals the size of B for finite sets is
the same as a by G B so what this says
is that if a by b and b by C then a by C
if there's a bijection from A to B in a
bijection from b to c then there's a
bijection from a to c corresponding
property for finite States again is
greater than or equal to if a is square
root will to be greater linked to the C
then a is the size of a is greater than
equal to the size of C and now it
corresponds to a similar statement about
the surjection relation a search BB
search C implies a search C and finally
more interesting one is that if a and B
are each greater than equal to each
other if a is granule to B and be the
size of B is greater than equal to a
then in fact they're the same size a is
equal to B now in correspond to the
following statement in terms of jek
shion's if a search b and b search a
then a by b now all of these facts
follow immediately for finite sets a and
B but we're going to be interested in
whether they hold for infinite set so
they follow immediately for finite sets
from the mapping lemma because the
mapping lemma says that these bhaijan
surge relations are the same as equal
and greater than or equal to sign so
again this is immediate from the mapping
lemma but now I can ask whether or not
these same properties hold for infinite
sets it's an exercise in reasoning about
properties of mappings and relations and
the answer is that the first two claims
go through easily if you're trying to
prove them for finite sets for infinite
sets the basic idea is let's look at the
first one says that if a if there's a
bijection from A to B and there's a by
checks you from B to C then there would
it be one from A to C how do you find it
well it's actually easy you just compose
the by action from A to B with the by CH
action from B to C and it's a very easy
exercise that the composition of by
actions is a bijection likewise the
composition of surjections is a
surjection
and that proves the second claim easily
but the third claim is much more
interesting and is not obvious it's
called the Schroder bernstein theorem
and it will come up a little bit in a
few more lectures